researchers have found that loneliness
is as bad for our health as smoking
15 cigarettes a day if you're lonely you
have a 30
higher chance of getting heart disease
if you're lonely you have
a 40 higher chance of getting dementia
if you're lonely you also have a higher
risk of getting stroke
if you're lonely and you're already ill
you're less likely to recover as well
you're an economist what are you doing
talking about loneliness
why are you interested in that so it was
it was a few things happening pretty
much at once that made me think
this is what i want to research next
first it was my students
i was noting that increasing numbers
were coming into my office
during office hours and confiding in me
how lonely and isolated they felt
and this was a new phenomenon i've been
teaching for a few years and
i hadn't experienced anything like it
before but
it was notable and the other thing that
i really noticed was that when i set my
students group assignments
increasingly or significant numbers of
them seem to be finding it increasingly
hard to
interact face to face and
when i raised it with a colleague um an
american professor who runs one of
america's big universities
he said to me we're seeing exactly the
same thing here in fact it's so bad here
that we're having to run remedial how to
read a face
in real life classes for our incoming
students because they're spending so
much time with their heads and their
screens
that they literally are
unable to read a roman person so that
was kind of one
just piece of information which i guess
i lodged
and then at the same time i was really
interested in my research
in the rise of right-wing populism
rise of people voting um
for people like le pen in france or
salvini in italy or trump of course in
the united states
and so i started
looking into this and i started
interviewing
uh voters and hearing from these kind of
voters and one thing that came out
time and time again from their stories
was how lonely
they felt or at least how lonely they
had felt
until they found community in
this far right populist kind of
gathering
and i found that disturbing
but also really interesting and a kind
of way of making sense of what was going
on
that i hadn't come across before and
then the third inside
these are all happening at roughly the
same time was i had bought
and i apologize already in advance if
this is annoying for anyone who's
listening
i bought an alexa so i'm whispering it
in case she starts going off
and um and i noticed myself becoming
increasingly attached
to my own alexa and
uh and it got me thinking
about ai and social robots
and the role that they were inevitably
going to play
in coming years in helping us feel more
connected to each other and less
or in helping us feel less lonely and um
more connected maybe not to each other
but to something at least
and i started researching that and
started to realize that
actually what we've been seeing and this
is before the pandemic and this may
speak
very much to you chris was the rise
of what i call the loneliness economy an
entire economy that had sprung up really
speaking to people's need for what
um the famous 20th century
um sociologist emile durkheim called
collective effervescence
the need for people to have
shared experiences together in person
and i'm saying this might resonate with
you because of course with your
club promoting um history
and really and we've seen it whether in
the rise of people who wanted to go
to clubs or the rise in people who
wanted to go to
things like escape rooms um or the
rising people who were
looking for community and things like
soul cycle
what we've been seeing um in the years
preceding the pandemic was really
a rise in this appetite for community
whether it was in a non-paid for form or
in a paid for commercialized form
so it was those three different things
together that made me realize that
loneliness
was a way really of making sense perhaps
a prism
through which to understand what was
going on in the world the big societal
um shifts and political shifts that have
been going on
how do you define loneliness so
i define loneliness in a broader sense
to the sense that
some people listening might think of it
i define loneliness as not only feeling
disconnected from your friends and
family and craving
um connection with them although it is
of course that too
i also define loneliness as feeling
disconnected
from your employer your government
from feeling uncared for and supported
not only from those who are meant to be
close to you but from
your work but by your workplace or your
government too
so for me loneliness is political
as well as personal and its drivers
are um economic technological
um demographic not only to do with how
we treat ourselves
and each other i imagine one of the
challenges that you're going to come up
against when researching loneliness is
that
all of that's very subjective and we
don't have
we can try and make an objective metric
from a very subjective feeling but it's
like trying to rate happiness or
trying to write any other sort of
emotion we don't know what it's like to
be another person's consciousness
so their level of loneliness and ours we
can try and give it as best to scale as
we can rate from one to five if this
statement
somewhat agree disagree etc but it's
always going to be slightly messy i
imagine
and the statistics around that must be
similarly messy as well what what
statistics did you find around
loneliness levels
so i think that's basically such an
interesting point that you raised
because it's something that i grappled
with so much
as i was doing my research and i ended
up thinking about loneliness and you're
right there is with all emotions
that challenge you know i'm very lonely
is my very lonely the same as you're
very lonely
but it's also i realized it's like pain
as well
because if somebody says i'm in a lot of
pain physical pain
we also don't know whether they're
physical their very pain
is equivalent to your very pain like
they're stubbing their toe
might be like you having a poker put in
your eye we just don't know
so there is that challenge with with um
these kind of metrics for sure whether
it's loneliness
depression anxiety or physical pain even
but um assuming that we're in the
ballpark at least with these kind of
figures
um and i think that's a fair assumption
what the research shows really clearly
is that loneliness even before the
pandemic was a really serious problem
with one in five
uk adults saying that they felt lonely
always almost at the time and
half of 18 to 24 year olds
saying that they felt lonely regularly i
mean that's an astounding figure
and in the workplace that also an
incredibly lonely place for many 60
of uk workers so that they feel lonely
at work
um one in five american workers say that
they don't have a single friend
in the workplace so um loneliness really
a very
pervasive uh feeling
throughout our society which the
pandemic has
significantly amplified um and research
that's come out in the last few months
um really shows that very clearly with
especially
with three groups especially being um
finding themselves even more lonely
through the pandemic
the young people on low income
and women so these are the three groups
who
i mean everyone on average feels
lonelier but those
three groups in particular um feel
especially lonely or have been feeling
especially lonely
i remember listening to a
i want to say a podcast i don't tend to
dip in much
into the sort of um women on women world
of podcasts but this one was really
fascinating
they were talking about
sympathizing with women who are single
and doing lockdown alone
uh because of the need for the oxytocin
release from being close
like physically close to people um and
that was a
an insight that i totally hadn't thought
of um you know
a bloke for me that hugs and stuff yeah
that
i can they're all right but i don't
really need them that much and
seeing it from that side that made a lot
of sense
i thought you're meant to be warmer up
north than likely more
you know insta kind of hugging the salt
of the earth up here you know
everyone's terrified of hugging now it's
that weird it's that weird album
isn't it yeah exactly um so out of all
of the different groups
it's surprising i think it might be
surprising to some people it was
surprising to me upon reading the book
that that 18 to 24 age bracket is
suffering because you just presume
between the age of 18 and 24 that
everyone's just
swimming in late night house parties and
uh a morning book club and a ride to the
gym with your friends and all this sort
of stuff but it seems like that's
quite the opposite especially given that
that's the age that people are at
university
a higher education so that will be
chunked into fairly
you know you're forced to see people
some of the lectures i had at newcastle
were
150 people strong i wanted less people
around me not more
it seems like that's changing so i think
firstly you can be lonely in a crowd i
mean
so in the same way that you are not
necessarily lonely if you're on your own
um so i think that's one factor but
you're right
i think that was really surprising to me
as well how
lonely the young are in fact the young
and the loneliest generation and when we
think about loneliness we often
think about it being the elderly the
loneliness but that just isn't the case
it is the young
the data is really clear on this who are
the loneliest i think
you know what differentiates the young
in particular
is their usage of mobile phones and
social media and i really
began my research feeling really
agnostic on this point
and i had no agenda beforehand
but as i dug into the academic research
and as i
interviewed many teenagers what came out
again and again
was the really um destructive role that
social media in particular was playing
in their lives now of course again this
is on average
and so there are going to be people for
whom social media
has been a lifeline the lgbtq kid in a
small village somewhere who
you know wasn't physically around anyone
who was like them
um it may well have found their
community
on instagram say but um
but on average it seems that these
um platforms are really playing a
significant role in the rise of young
people's loneliness and it's for a few
reasons
in the first is quite simply that
these are platforms designed to be
addictive
to keep drawing us in with their kind of
twinkly lights and color and flashing
and endless scrolls and
um and all the ways that they've kind of
designed them to do so
and the more we're on the phones i mean
the less present
we are with those actually around us and
so the quality
of our face-to-face relationships are
diminished and i i've been guilty of it
myself
maybe been scrolling on my social media
feed
in the room with my husband's and um
not really even hearing him because my
attention has been on my phone
but the social media playing uh the role
of um
kind of being a weapon not only of mass
destruction
but also a weapon of sorry not weapon of
mass destruction
um that was a bit far i think but social
media
you know not only playing a part of
being a weapon of mass distraction
i'd rather um i i don't know let me
not go too far here but um but also um
being a very excluding mechanism for
many young people it turns out
um in my interviews with teenagers
i remember peter for example a 14 year
old schoolboy telling me
very importantly about how invisible he
felt when he would post
on instagram and then be waiting waiting
waiting waiting for someone to like his
post and then when nobody did
asking himself what am i doing wrong or
claudia a teenager who told me about the
pain she felt
when she realized that her friends were
out without
her that said that they weren't going
out and she was scrolling through her
feed and saw them hanging out
without her and she had been excluded or
a parent who shared with me
the pain his daughter felt when she was
in a cafe with her friends
and everyone's phone pinged with a
whatsapp message
inviting them to a party and she didn't
even get the message but she had to
pretend that she had the message
so as to not appear so excluded so
um of course young people were excluded
in the past too this isn't
a contemporary phenomenon and yet what
makes it different now is that
because so much of their social
interaction has migrated onto their
screens
um whereas an adult
in their lives in the past might have
seen this is going on
and actually done something to intervene
so a teacher might have seen a child not
being asked to sit with others
or a parent might have noticed that
their kid wasn't being asked to do
something
um today the adult typically isn't aware
of it
whereas to all their peers the exclusion
is really yeah
it's invisible there's a lack of
visibility and there's some learned
helplessness
lack of visibility from a caregiver's
perspective looking in and then the
learned helplessness
yeah i mean it's easy to say uh just man
up you know that people have been
excluded for
all of time but there does seem to be a
corner that's turned
with social media the fact that
the ubiquity of it the messiness of it
jonathan hates
uh the coddling of the american mind
which i'm halfway through at the moment
is
really fascinating and terrifying around
this
there is a like a great wall
from teenagers around about 2012 to 2014
which is kind of when instagram came
around and it's just this
the crest of this tsunami that's kind of
moving through the demographic
and it's very much split into pre and
post yes
that time and uh and when we look at
rising uh
loneliness figures amongst this
generation they also
like massively shoot up from um
from then onwards but what's really
interesting is that
so we've been aware of that research
for a few years now but what we can
determine
um definitively was whether this was
just
um correlation or was it actually
causation was it because
people were on their social media
platforms that they were
um lonelier so it was hard to
disentangle that when all you knew was
that there was a kind of
the the periods corresponded but about
two years ago there was a really seminal
new piece of research done at stanford
university
obviously a top university where they
got 3 000
students um where they put half of those
into a control group
they were told to keep using their
facebook as usual the other group were
told to
delete their facebook for two months and
then they tracked
how the different groups responded and
the groups that were
off facebook fascinatingly it wasn't
that they then just spent more time on
other platforms
they actually spent less time on the
internet overall and more time in person
with friends and family but they were
also significantly
less lonely and significantly happier in
fact the researchers said that
deleting facebook is 40 as good for you
as actually having therapy
yeah [ __ ] the bed
that's a really astounding i mean i've
been
very sort of anti-social media
anti-technology
for three and a half years since i got
introduced to tristan harris from the
center for humane technology yes
um and i've kind of been on this flex
for a long time
but it does feel very much like i i
don't know what the solution is here i
think
um it needs to be emergent bottom-up it
needs a social change it requires people
to be able to self-regulate
despite the fact that there is billions
and billions of dollars in an army of
engineers behind every click
but it also requires perhaps some sort
of top-down litigation i know that we're
seeing screen time
yeah not not perhaps i think that
absolutely needs to be part of the
package and in many ways
i think we should think of social media
companies as the tobacco companies of
the 21st century
and as such they really should be
regulated as such um
strongly especially when it comes to
children
and in the uk there is actually just in
the last um
a few days there's been some real action
on this front with a new bill going
through parliament
um which will hold social media
companies accountable for online harm
not only for the most um egregious hate
speech but also
for when it comes to children um
negatively
negatively affecting them
psychologically so that is actually
a significant step um in what i believe
is the right direction
because although of course we
can try and resist our addiction
ourselves
i know how hard it is to do so i mean i
wouldn't i typically i'm not on social
media but when i have a book out i have
to go on social media
and i've really seen that how addicted
how quickly i've become
once i've been you know going on it on a
daily basis yeah the problem is once
those neurons have wired themselves in
they're not going anywhere they're there
for the rest of your life
um i i know what you mean about
yeah i mean although although even with
the addiction i
um one way that i managed to kind of
break it
is by being quite draconian and actually
just having
like not keep putting my phone so that
it's not
actually in arm's reach like i have to
physically distance myself
your phone outside of your bedroom is
the number one hack for reducing your
screen time
um but yeah i i saw the legislation that
you're talking about
i am concerned that that involves a
restriction of freedom of speech and we
get into a whole other conversation
to be had there it is going to be
difficult to
legislate top down and restrict the bad
that is ubiquitously bad platform wide
around social media
whilst getting into a more nuanced
discussion i think about
what we should and should not be are
they a publisher
are they a pipeline are they the
provider of information are they liable
for what's on their platform what does
that mean what do we
so on and so forth um one question
that i had that i thought was kind of
interesting what was the last time
in your research that you looked at that
we didn't have mass loneliness are we
going back to like the 1800s here or
so it's only in the 1800s that
you even re start reading about
loneliness
as a phenomenon so um so the phrase
itself
um the word lonely is something that
really only entered the
vernacular from the 1800s hundreds
onwards but i and i think um
you know it's partly because of how
people conceived of themselves
um in a religious context you know being
kind of you weren't lonely if you were
at one with god
and um so i think that's maybe part of
the reason why we didn't see
that uh ex that sentiment expressed
before but
i that doesn't say that people weren't
lonely before
uh because i'm sure there were many
people who
felt lonely if you were um
living in an abusive relationship
whether that was in the um 16th or 15th
or 14th century that imagine
imagine
[Music]
a peasant if you were in a poor house if
you were you know i'm sure there were
lots of circumstances that felt many
even if it wasn't something
that was talked about then so what's
changed obviously we've got this
contribution of technology what else has
changed that's driving this
loneliness yeah a number of factors uh
for example more people live on their
own now than
any time before it's not as i said that
everyone who lives on their own is
lonely that of course isn't the case but
if you live on your own you are
disproportionately likely to be lonely
and disproportionately likely to feel
lonely more often
we do less with other people than we did
in the past
we go to church less we
are less likely to be members of trade
unions
we are um less likely
to do things like go to parent teacher
um evenings if we're a parent so we just
do less with others than we did in the
past
and then there's what i would call the
neoliberal
mindset which is really the particular
capitalist
mindset that has dominated the last
few decades ever really since the 1980s
when
it was promulgated by margaret thatcher
and ronald reagan
and this is really a mindset that firmly
put the individual
at the center a kind of me eye-centric
philosophy that um
really valorized self-interest
and selfishness and we even see this in
the way that pop song lyrics evolved
from the 1980s onwards
where we see words like we us
and our being steadily supplanted by
words like
me myself i which is fascinating and
an eye-centric me centric world
was inevitably always going to be a
lonely one
yeah that's interesting i think it's
important i'm a massive champion of a
meritocracy i'm also a huge champion of
upward mobility personal sovereignty
taking agency in control of your own
actions
but i can see how that taken to its
extreme
can lead to a loneliness kind of talking
about
it's the same theme throughout all of
this that
we want the good bits of what we can get
out that's good but as soon as we start
to push it to an extreme with technology
with independence and sort of
sovereignty of the individual
when you take it to the extreme you also
then get malignant effects that come as
a byproduct of that too
and finding the messy middle finding
what's good of that without taking too
much of it i think is a
real challenge and also recognizing that
there are
trade-offs we sometimes have to make
between
individualism and community
between freedom and fraternity
these aren't binary choices they have to
make but it's recognizing that
we have to give probably a bit of one to
get more of the other
what about city design yes
that's something i look at a lot in my
book in there's a whole chapter on that
cities are and again some people are
surprised by this finding but cities
it turns out are the loneliest habitats
in which to live you might think with
all these people
around you you wouldn't be lonely well
it turns out that isn't the case
it's partly about the speed of the city
you know
everyone rushing go go go in fact
research i found this fascinating
that the richer a city the faster its
citizens walk and also the
denser a city the less civil its
citizens
are to each other which i find
fascinating as well so cities
these rushing places where people are
not really civil to each other or that
civil to each other
um you know are inevitably going to be
lonelier places
but cities also designed in most cases
more really for cars all too often than
people
the scale of a city can be alienating
and isolating with increasingly
what i call hostile architecture
dotted around the city so um
benches are lights
uh spikes grills designed with the
express purpose
of excluding certain groups
for example there's um a shopping mall
which has a very special kind of pinky
light
in the um bathrooms to dissuade
teenagers
from hanging out there because it shows
up acne
um there's also this kind of
high-pitched sonic
sound that some other shopping malls are
using
which apparently only young people can
hear it something about
what there's something that happens in
your ears as you get older
when you and you don't hear these
frequencies as well
and also to dissuade people from
young people from hanging out there we
see it with
benches even um there's a bench near to
where i live the camden bench it's
called
designed specifically this kind of
sloping bench
um to really dissuade skateboarders to
skate in it
homeless people to line it but of course
then being a bench which no one really
can sit on including the elderly woman
who might have wanted to sit there
watch the world go by and chat to
passers-by
so cities yeah in many ways being
designed
intentionally to exclude thereby
making them lonely for significant
slaves of people in them
i went to rome last year and i went to
go see the coliseum and as a part of
that the tour guide
showed us that i'm going to get this
wrong it's something like 100 000 people
i think that the colosseum at its
absolute max could have in
and they could exit all 100 000 people
in under 10 minutes
and one of the strategies that they
implemented
was that the steps as you were going
down they were sloped towards the exit
so you couldn't slow down as soon as you
begin moving down the steps your feet
have to go faster
to catch you up and i'm like well in a
world that doesn't have
suing and sort of litigative lawsuits
around i fell down your steps getting
out of the gladiatorial arena
like when that that isn't an option i
think it probably makes for a
remakes were a good idea to get people
out of the stadium quickly but not
safely and also probably a bit of a [ __ ]
bench
what about what are some of the most
extreme examples
of loneliness that you found
ah it's probably
carl so i had heard
that people um
paid to be cuddled that that there was
that a growing industry a growing part
of what i called the loneliness economy
was people paying to be cuddled and
i started investigating this online
initially
and came across a woman called jean jean
is a professional cuddler
um she is in venice beach in california
and she introduced me to some of her
clients and when i was in los angeles i
met with one of them
let's call him carl and
he came in i met him in a starbucks
i think it was johnny cash playing on
the
radio and he um walked in
nice looking man early 50s
sultan purple hair chinos button-down
shirt
sat down and told me his story and it
turned out he had moved to los angeles
a few years before from a small town and
didn't know anyone in the city and he
was divorced
and he didn't know anyone in the city
and felt really lonely
and really craved intimacy he had tried
online dating
but it really wasn't for him he said and
he then heard about paid cuddling
and he started seeing gene and he said
it absolutely transformed his life
now this by the way he's a media
executive
earning a six-figure salary single i'm
going to guess
single working for a big media
corporation
yeah started seeing gene he said it
transformed his life um
he went from being really down really
depressed to feeling really positive
his productivity at work he told me shut
up
you know a fascinating story and so he
told me he was seeing gene
once a week i said gosh that's a lot and
then he said you're not
using my real name are you and i said no
and he said
well if i'm let me then tell you
something else and i said well and he
said well seeing gene
hasn't ended up being enough and so i'm
actually seeing other people
to pay to be cuddled and by the way we
this was making very clear this was not
a sexual thing
this was about intimacy about wanting to
be held
touched not in a sexual way and um
and i said gosh that must be really
expensive how are you paying for it and
he said
i'm living in my car
this was somebody who was so craving
connection and intimacy that in order to
pay for it
he was living in his car showering at
the 24 7 gym
he was parking outside leaving his feet
in the bridge
in work i mean i found that such a
disturbing story
such a sad story um yeah
so i think that was probably one of the
most extreme ones i came across
on the other end of the age spectrum
um another story that i did find really
moving
was what's going on in japan with
elderly pensioners who are the fastest
growing
demographic when it comes to people
being incarcerated people going to jail
and the reason for researchers who've
studied this phenomenon
is because they're so lonely this group
of pensioners who
intend her committing crimes like
shoplifting in order to be jailed
that they want to be jailed in order to
find the company and companionship
that jail provides now a 40 percent of
these jailed pensioners
um have no relationship with their
families 50
haven't seen any friends in recent
months even
so again a really sad story but these
are
these are at the extremes it's important
to again remember
how pervasive loneliness is amongst all
of us
how do you get jailed it's a japanese
granny
shoplifting of course
a bit just really badly done
like really obvious chocolate like
walking out with a huge teddy bear or
like a tv under your arm or something
if you're elderly you might not be able
to carry the tv
maybe the teddy bear maybe the teddy
bear marshmallows
uh or the light objects yeah i uh
i i don't really know what to think
about that i mean the your man from
la obviously that's that's a
very bizarre example i wonder how much
of that is a pathology on his part and
how much of that is a byproduct of
loneliness
um well what was interesting was i
actually went
to gene's cuddle sanctuary as well when
i was in
um is it like a sort of a
no i don't use the word brothel because
i know that we're steering clear of sexy
stuff here but it kind of like a sort of
a madam's house but it's all different
would you like to cuddle in the pink
room today or in the cloud or in the
unicorn lounge
so i've got to say before i when i was
really nervous and i
was thinking what am i letting myself in
for
but actually it was much more akin to
a yoga studio with with
with the people coming in yeah
yeah it didn't have incense but it kind
of had
you know beanbag type things on the
floor and like you know those
tubes that p that in gyms you can kind
of use to learn
and do your exercises so it's a bit like
that dotted around and mats on the floor
kind of like those mats that you see in
yoga studios and the people attending so
it was a
group cuddle session the people are
attending up with random
random other humans for a cuddle so what
happens is you pay
to attend and then you sit around
um in a circle and you'll meet each
other
what was really interesting was everyone
looked so normal i mean this did
you know i didn't know what to expect
but everyone just these really look
they look like people who were going to
their local gym class or yoga class
you know wearing kind of comfortable
clothes physical deficiencies
or people not at all and then
and what happened then was you
kind of moved around with two different
people
and were cuddled and cuddled there oh so
it's like a
car keys in the bowl type job but for
for that and then you swap and you
change and you keep on going i had to
cuddle with you
yeah but you keep your clothes on and
and it's all very consensual so you say
uh would it be okay if
i put my arm around you and then the
person has to say yes or no
but what was really i mean it wasn't
really for me i didn't get played you
don't have to go
to my no i did have a guy did you ever
get did you have a go with jeannie
i had a guy yes i had to go yeah i mean
i i went i like
experienced it and the experience was
i'd say not really for me
i think my british reserve kind of
didn't
didn't play well to the group cuddling
but i i went for it
i you know i went for it see what it
felt like but what was really
interesting afterwards
because this is speaking to whether carl
had some weird pathology
i don't think he did because you know
this group of people who i chatted to
afterwards
they were so normal and their reasons
for it were just
quite straightforward one of them um a
woman from texas again
an attractive woman from texas she'd
moved to
um california she was divorced she said
you know she didn't want to be in a
relationship right now but she
craved having some intimacy and some
touch
another woman a university administrator
in her twenties
she told me again that she it was
intimacy she was missing connection a
feeling of connection
in an increasingly disconnected world so
um it was actually interesting how
not strange the people were
yeah who were doing it what happens
physiologically when someone's lonely
so when we're lonely we think of
loneliness really as being something
that only affects our
mental health but actually loneliness
does your right affect us
physiologically too
it's really because of how we've evolved
because we are essentially creatures of
togetherness hardwired to connect
our bodies have been designed so that
when we're not
connected to others when we feel lonely
um
it sends alarm bells ringing kind of
putting us into a
really strong state of fight or flight
so our blood pressure goes up
our heart rate goes up our levels of
cortisol which we can measure
in our saliva go up when we're lonely
all of us is
all of these things just essentially
telling our body
stop being lonely go and find someone to
hang out with and be with
um and the trouble is that even though
in many ways this is a great uh piece of
evolutionary design in the modern world
when so many people are lonely for
protracted periods of time
this actually makes you really quite
unwell and it's like if you were driving
a car
in first gear um you know for the first
initial moments that's great that's what
you want to be doing but if you're doing
it over time that's really going to
damage
your engine and so too when you're
lonely for protracted of
periods of time are our bodies
physically
damaged um in fact researchers have
found that loneliness is as
bad for our health as smoking 15
cigarettes a day
i'd seen that start how how does that
tie in because obviously i'm not going
to get emphysema you know i'm not going
to be impacting my lungs do you know
can you dig into that a little bit more
yes so um so
we know for example that if you're
lonely
you have a 30 higher chance of
getting heart disease if you're lonely
you have
a 40 higher chance of getting dementia
if you're lonely you also have a higher
risk of getting stroke
if you're lonely and you're already ill
you're like less likely to recover as
well
so it's all those sorts of factors why
is that manifesting do you know did they
look at why that's that's coming up like
you've got
some pretty strong physiological
adaptations mal adaptations
yes well it's really because of this
continuous state of
being on red alert fight or flight
high blood pressure high stress levels
um
are really bad for us when they're
sustained because what they do is they
dampen our ability to fight
infection and they increase our
inflammation levels in our body
and both of those our ability to fight
infection and
raised inflammation levels um are really
bad for our life expectancy and for our
health
so that's that's why essentially i
wonder
how much
what we're talking about here are
diseases which will tend to manifest in
older age
but we're talking about a group of
specifically young people
it's across the spectrum but some very
young people i wonder
how much harm can be done and then
undone you know the person who used to
party really hard when they're young and
they've now decided to go t
total i wonder what sort of chronic
changes we're going to see from young
people who are maybe
um who just suffer with loneliness then
perhaps they get into a happy marriage
and they have kids and they have lots of
dogs and cats and
live in the country away from a big city
and stuff like that i wonder
it'll be fascinating to look at that in
you know sort of 50 years time
and see what's actually going on so
the bad news is that researchers have
looked at this
and what they've found is that even
relatively
short periods of loneliness so under two
years
of feeling lonely um can have a
significant impact on your life
expectancy [ __ ]
[ __ ] the bed but the good news is okay
the good news on the other hand let me
on to that then is that
um actively helping others
feeling connected to others feeling part
of the community
is good for our health and actually is
shown to
improve our life expectancy so
even if you've had a period of
loneliness if you then invest
like actually invest in strengthening
your relationships
in being part of a community
and also in caring for others because
people who
give no one else any help it turns out
also have their life expectancy slashed
whereas helping others
makes you live longer so there are
things you can do
um to repair that damage from your past
sitting is the new smoking was a term
that i coined when i bought this
beautiful standing desk last year
but it's now loneliness is also the new
so sitting all loneliness of both the
new smoking and you're not allowed and
smoking's also
smoking's the old smoking but it's still
going so you need to watch out for that
there is
a number of ways that you can reduce
your life expectancy so moving through
this
it seems like a common antidote here
just off the top of my head is
find a partner that loves you find a
partner that loves you build a family
surely that's one of the most robust
solutions to not being lonely
i'm sure that there's many parents that
are listening that wish that they could
feel lonely having to take
cindy to school in the morning and
joseph to football on a night time and
stuff like that
well again just being in a relationship
doesn't necessarily
alleviate loneliness and it can actually
make you lonelier one of the reasons
women
is one of the groups which have become
lonelier through this pandemic
is because of the rise of domestic abuse
that we've seen during the pandemic too
and i'm loathe to make marriage
the solution for the contemporary
loneliness crisis
i think what your question does speak to
you correctly however
is the importance of having strong
relationships in our lives
and investing in our relationships and
our support structures which
don't have to be those um
traditional ones of a marriage or a
partner
investing in our friendships also can
alleviate loneliness very successfully
too can a friendship
replace the level of contact that you
get from a relationship though
we're talking about someone that you get
to spend some time with but unless you
decide to actually live in a house
together perhaps with this friend for a
really con expanded period of time
that compared with the number of the
sheer number of hours the time and
attention that you're going to get
in a marriage surely the i'm aware that
it's time together doesn't necessarily
equal the level of connection
but the presumption is or at least i
would hope that most people
who stay in a marriage for a long time
hopefully it's not abusive hopefully it
has got a level of connection you're
having kids you're trying to support
them raise them create a family that is
meaningful and has purpose and
it moves towards a common goal of
building a better life for everybody
that's within that household
i wonder how many friends equal a good
partner
if that makes sense i think a good
marriage is a wonderful thing
for sure but i'm not sure how many
people are in
a good marriage and so that's right
probably suggest
exactly and so that being the case i
would say that
investing in good friendships um
is really important i suppose good
friendships are quite robust aren't they
you tend to
see people go in and out of
relationships more quickly than they do
lifelong friends
yeah i mean my friendships like we're
really there for each other
i i really believe that and and have
seen it through the years
yeah let's talk about remote working
obviously
upon starting whatever three years ago
writing your book
and then hitting 2020 like the loneliest
year in history the creation of the word
lockdown the creation of the word sort
of
tiered uh social isolation
you know social discipline social
discipline sorry yes i mean
yes no social isolation as well but
social distancing that such and
kind of it's almost like i mean that we
were prescribing
telling people to socially
yeah it's not it's not been a a year of
a glossary
filled book of words that's nice is it
it wasn't like
social cuddling or like house
fun or so it was all like sort of fairly
nasty words
thinking about that i know that you
talked about um
the work industry how people feel in the
workplace what's your thoughts on the
new normal of remote working
so i don't believe it is the new normal
firstly um
because i think there was this initial
euphoria
uh when remote working was introduced
but by and large this is really wearing
thin
and i think most people by now um are
expressing quite clearly to their
employers
but they actually want to go back to the
office um especially young people
um who you know maybe
have got a really not that ideal work
environment to be working from um and
i'm missing the
chats at the um water cooler and
and when you're making your cups of
coffee in the shared kitchen so um
so the idea that people actually really
want
to keep on working remotely i don't
think it's the case
of course some companies you know have
been looking at how things
have been unfolding over recent months
and they're looking at this wiggly
thinking that this is
a justification for them now massively
reducing their physical footprint
why provide offices if everyone can just
work from home
but i would caution that because what i
discovered in my research was that
lonely workers
not only feel bad themselves but lonely
workers are bad
for business itself with loaning workers
less productive less motivated less
efficient
than workers who are not and also more
likely to jump ship
in a study of thousands of workers
across a number of countries um
they found that workers who were lonely
were 60
more likely to quit [ __ ]
i i was really interested around the
insights of
open office spaces versus cubicle office
spaces
and the fact that open office spaces
actually cause people to feel more
lonely and
you were saying i think it was on chris
evans or something that you sometimes go
into the office you got your
the noise cancelling headphones in
because you're like it's gonna be loud
in here and annoying and all the rest of
it
and i can totally see how the openness
of an open plan office actually causes
people to open up less because they know
that everybody in the room essentially
can hear what they're going to say um
yeah it is it's so perhaps the new
abnormal
we could call remote working and i i
definitely get it as well that from the
pure rationalist utilitarian perspective
well look you've saved
10 hours a week on your commute to work
you know half an hour there and back
each day and
plus look you get to work with pajama
bottoms on you and you have to wear a
shirt on your top half now because you
do
zoom calls or no pants at all as some of
my friends have
sent me selfies of just them in their
boxes with a shirt and tie on top doing
a zoom
doing a zoom meeting i've got no idea
what you've got
yeah look well that's that's precisely
what you can only see up to my waist
um
yeah that that is never going to get
boring
but not only does that not speak to
necessarily the full gamut of
requirements that we have as a human
but we don't even know what we want a
lot of the time we think
well look i've saved this time i'm
spending more time i get to go to the
gym more i get to do this than the other
but the um the thread of knowing what
the inputs are in our life and how they
make us feel
you know we'd never need a therapist or
a doctor if we were
fully cognizant about those things right
but we're not yeah we don't we
we don't know just how much we need to
awkwardly say hello to the cleaner on
our way in and our way out or like the
receptionist that we're not too sure
does she like me does she not like me
i think that's one of the things
interestingly that
the pandemic and the past however many
months it now is
has made us however recognize
more than we were aware of before those
little micro exchanges
and how much they actually matter
whether it is
that chat in the cafe to the server or
whether it
is the conversation you might have in
your local bookstore or whether it is
um the um hello
um those conversations you might have
at a club in the evening with those
people who
you don't ever see outside of the club
but in some
shape or form they are in some way who
you'd consider to be your friends
i think or even um those colleagues in
the office who maybe you never
really thought of as friends but now as
months have gone by you're thinking
actually they kind of were friends at
least in some way actually
smelly bill and and and dopey joanna
whatever you know the weird nicknames
that you've got for all of the people i
don't know where you've been working
um but um
but yes so i think one of the things
actually that we are more attuned to
is how important those micro exchanges
actually are and when it comes to remote
work
there was a big experiment done in china
a couple of years ago
where a big company half of their
employees were sent
to work from home for six months
and at the end of six months they were
given the option you can either return
to the office
or um stay at home and the vast majority
rushed back even though they had really
long commutes the
craving for face-to-face interaction was
actually stronger
that's really interesting i'm reading
the happiness hypothesis by john i'm
good just jonathan height
like down the rabbit hole at the moment
and um
he says that the length of commute to
work
is one of the um easiest ha reducing
your commute to work is one of the
easiest hacks to increase happiness
across your life
but because people tend specifically in
america
tend to prefer to have a big square
footage house because it's impressive
and it gives them status and it makes
them feel important and so on and so
forth
they'll tend to live further outside of
a city so they can afford a bigger house
which causes bigger commute
but the converse of that is that
obviously the commute to work
enables you to see the people who are at
work so perhaps
perhaps that's a price and it comes back
to what we were saying before right like
these gradations what is the price that
we have to pay to get ourselves to this
particular situation
something else i've been thinking a lot
about this year obviously my industry
club promo
i employ up to about a thousand students
every year who are 18 to 21
freshers arriving at university you know
some fresh-faced wet behind the ears
young guys and girls who've
arrived from leeds on manchester or
birmingham or something and they come to
newcastle full of gumption and ready to
do geordie shore
and they have been through
like this year as a student must have
been total hell
you've been locked down in your halls of
residence burley halls in manchester
you'll have seen was 1700 students
socially isolated not even able to go
down to the front door to collect
delivery or amazon
prime parcels for stuff that they needed
all manner of crazy crazy situations
and i wonder we've sort of talked about
what the um
more small gathering interpersonal
one-to-one one-to-two
situation but that collective
effervescence that you spoke about the
way that people feel sports fans feel
when they get to chant their team's name
when they're watching a game go on
the way that it feels when your favorite
song come like when whap comes on in a
club or whatever it is
and you you're able to dance with your
friends and you have you go up and you
meet people
um first off i wonder what sort of an
effect that's going to have and secondly
i wonder how long it's going to be
it's a broader question how long it's
going to be before
we look at the world we have now social
distancing
masks outside um limited social contact
no clubs no bars no mingling between
groups when we see because
even now i see on tv the old world the
world from pre 2020
and think that looks alien that looks
bizarre that obviously wasn't filmed
this year that's not the world that i
inhabit right now
um so yeah a whole host of potential
sort of negative downstream
effects from what's going on so i'm
actually more optimistic
on this front one of us i think if we
look i think if we look back
historically there's reason for optimism
if you think just a few years after the
1918
spanish flu bars nightclubs
cafes were heaving the roaring twenties
after all yeah the roaring twenties came
after
right up the back of the 1918 spanish
flu
a situation very similar to this if you
think about how in taipei
as soon as people were allowed to 5 000
people were congregating each night to
watch
phantom of the opera now like in the
last few months
if you think about if you've if you've
been tracking what's going on
in sydney or christchurch
um so australia or new zealand we're
seeing music festivals packed with
people
nightclubs packed with people dancing in
israel
after yoga studios were able to open
again
people were encircling the blocks you
know
i really firmly believe that
our fundamental desire to be with others
is going to prevail and you know i'm in
absolutely no doubt about
it so he's saying that i can be very
bullish about my industry over the next
few years as soon as we get back out the
other side of that well that's good i i
would
i would even yes and i would even go i
would say
be really bullish because in the same
way that after a period
of um fasting
we become more hungry after this
enforced
social recession i think our desire to
be with others is going to be stronger
than ever
one structural limitation that we're
going to come up against there is the
f b nightlife leisure industry is
getting
pounded and it is not cheap to run
um there's a big venue up here you'll
have been to a tiger tiger before at
some point in the year
uh in your life and um they were
purchased by a company called deltic
huge big uh publicly traded company they
own a ton of different venues they
turned them into prisms and they bought
lava ignite and they bought luminar they
used to have liquid and lq
big big group and on saturday
i had to drive into the newcastle one
to pull all of our inflatables out
before the administrators go in
this week and i turn up outside and
there's a queue of lorries
five lorries ten cars all in this little
side street that's usually that my
secret parking spot
and they're anything that isn't stapled
or drilled into the floor and some
things that are
are just being lifted out of this
building before the administrators come
in and put a big chain around the door
in a couple of days time
so you think like that is going to bring
the guardrails in on what people can do
you know how many yoga studios how many
gyms bars
restaurants little independents plus the
ones that you might have thought would
have been able to weather the storm
because they got deep pockets
someone like a big publicly traded
national company like there's no one
that's safe from going pop at the moment
no and it's absolutely tragic i mean my
sister has a yoga studio and she's
experiencing this
kind of first hand so i mean it's
absolutely tragic and yet from
the ashes of these
businesses new um pro-community
commercialized ventures will inevitably
rise
inevitably correct and for those and for
those who can
hunker down and whether the storm i mean
there is light out there at the end of
this tunnel for sure
i like that if you were to give someone
a prescription
for how they can avoid loneliness as
best they can what would your best tips
be
so if you're feeling lonely yourself
um is there something that you're into
doing
where you might be able to find other
people to do it with
so i for example i'm into improv i do
i'm part of a week
i do improv every week um in the old
world i would
go and meet up with my fellow
improvisers
but in the on zoom world we've migrated
to zoom for now
but um but that is really great having
something that you're interested in so
whether it's
improvising or singing or
um i don't know playing chess collecting
stamps whatever it is
is there something that you're into
where you could find other people
for now it may have to be on zoom but
hopefully afterwards in person
um is there something you can do to help
others
uh helping others is a really good way
of
feeling less lonely yourself feeling
more connected to other people
um but you're also of course doing
really good
for someone else at the same time you're
also as the helper getting what's known
as the helpers high
a physiological response dopamine rush
which which feels good as well so
helping others
feels good too so um just a couple of
practical things
if you're lonely you could try out yeah
the
uh i have a friend who did classics at
liverpool crazy smart girl
and um she came out and she got she
walked her first having done no
preparation for the entire three years
she did the degree
and started volunteering on below
minimum wage at a
dog's shelter looking after abandoned
dogs
and i was like one you've just dropped
40 grand on your degree what are you
doing
and she's like like i've never been this
happy in my life just like assisting
dogs and
and i mean anyone that's around that
many dogs is going to be happy
but she she she took that as more
valuable than doing a
monetizing a 40 000 pound first
in classics from liverpool so you think
yeah
it makes a lot of sense surprisingly
being selfless is one of the most
selfish
things that you can do sometimes
self-interested
yes self-interested it is uh if people
are
sharing there we go if people want to
check out more about you
and uh find out more stuff where should
they go
um they can either go to my website
www.marina.com they can follow me on all
my social platforms
which i am currently still on and by the
book
um it's got lots more about what we've
been talking about today the lonely
century
available in all good independent
workshops as well as of course online
fantastic that will be linked on amazon
in the show notes below if you buy it
through that you will be supporting the
show at no extra cost to yourself
and it's anybody now that's able to get
just their first name
dot com as their url like that is
such a rarity you must be one of only a
very few people that's able to do that
so
i congratulate you on a fun fantastic
url marina today's
today's been really cool thank you very
much for your time thank you so much for
your time thank you
[Music]